HOWEVER, ABRAHAM LINCOLN
WAS REQUESTING
EDWIN PERFORM SHAKESPEARE
AT GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS.
AM I [bleep] IT UP, GUYS?
WHAT'S UP, GUYS?
WHAT--IS IT [bleep] IT UP?
OKAY, OKAY.
[mumbling]
OKAY.
RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
AT THE FORD'S THEATRE,
WHEN JOHN WILKES BOOTH
WAS GESTICULATING,
ABRAHAM LINCOLN'S SISTER-IN-LAW
IS LIKE,
I THINK HE'S POINTING AT YOU,
ABRAHAM.
AND ABRAHAM LINCOLN IS LIKE,
IT DOES SEEM LIKE
HE'S POINTING AT ME.
UHH...
THIS IS A LITTLE WEIRD.
HE SHOULD, UH, YOU KNOW,
NOT BE POINTING AT ME
DURING THIS PARTICULAR LINE
BECAUSE IT'S SORT OF...
AGGRESSIVE.
IN NOVEMBER 1864,
EDWIN BOOTH IS LIKE,
HEY, YOU KNOW,
I WANNA GET TO KNOW YOU BETTER.
WE'VE HAD SOME HARD TIMES.
LET'S DO A PLAY
TOGETHER AGAIN,
FOR ONE PERFORMANCE ONLY--
JULIUS CAESAR.
JOHN WILKES' FAVORITE ROLE
WAS BRUTUS,
THE MAN THAT EXECUTES
A TYRANT.
AND EDWIN BOOTH IS LIKE,
I GET TO PLAY BRUTUS.
[trumpets sounding]
FOR ONE PERFORMANCE ONLY,
IN THE PRODUCTION OF
JULIUS CAESAR,
EDWIN SAID,
"SIC SEMPER TYRANNIS,"
AND EVERYONE LOVES IT.
CRITICS SAID THAT IT WAS
THE MOST IMPORTANT SHOW
OF ALL TIME.
SO JOHN WILKES BOOTH
STARTED GETTING INVOLVED
WITH A SECRET
CONFEDERATE SOCIETY
AND HAD MASTERMINDED A PLAN
TO KIDNAP LINCOLN.
UHH...
MM-MM.